how's it going everybody it's Warren and
I've been getting a ton of messages
about a particular topic slash photo
since the Avengers end game trailer came
out a lot of people are sending me this
photo and are freaking out because it
looks like you can see Groot on the ship
with Tony and I must admit that it does
sort of look like he's on the ship with
Tony and I myself started freaking out
because I was wondering how did I miss
this I did two trailer breakdowns I've
watched the trailer many times how did I
miss him in this scene so I'm looking at
this picture and everybody pretty much
sent the same picture I think it's the
same one going around the internet right
now so I'm looking at it and I'm
wondering how because Groot was a victim
of the decimation but if you play the
trailer and watch this part it's
actually pretty evident that this is
100% not Groot
so here's the part of the trailer where
everybody thinks that Groot is in this
scene and in the beginning yes this
looks like Groot but if you play through
it you can clearly tell that it's not
this looks to be some sort of seat or
console the same one that Tony is
leaning on in this frame right here it
doesn't really matter what matters is
this is not Groot so if you see a photo
online anywhere where it looks like
Groot is on the ship with Tony Stark
he's not and if anybody tries to tell
you otherwise just have them watch the
trailer so there you have it Groot is
not on the ship I thought I'd address
this because so many people are freaking
out about it they wouldn't show anybody
who is victim of the decimation in the
teaser trailer or maybe even any trailer
at all also don't forget about my
giveaway I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
I'll be picking a winner at the end of
the month on New Year's Eve as always
thank you all so much for watching we'll
forth
[Music]